Now let's do a quiz on the benefits
of branch prediction. Let's say we have the classical
5-stage pipeline. The fetch, decode, execute, memory and
write. The branch is fully resolved in the execute,
the third stage. Fully resolved means that we
finally know the correct PC from which we should
fetch the next instruction. In this processor, we
fetch nothing until we are sure what to fetch,
and we execute many many iterations of this loop. We add minus one to R1,
we add R2 to itself, and then we branch if R1 is not equal zero back to
the loop. The question for you what is the speed up over this achieve if we
had perfect predictor? Meaning for after every instruction
fetched we know which one should be fetched next.